hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today's topic is the afrikaans language
a couple of weeks ago i released a video
on the dutch language
which you can find right here this is
kind of a follow-up to that video
because afrikaans is a descendant of
dutch
that means that just like dutch
afrikaans is a west germanic language
afrikaans has a total of about 7.1
million native speakers with
6.85 million of those in south africa
that's about 13.5 percent of the south
african population
that makes it the third most widely
spoken language in south africa and it's
the majority language in the western
half of the country
that means northern cape and western
cape provinces it's the native language
of about 61 percent of white south
africans and it's the native language of
more than three quarters of
quote-unquote colored south africans
about 3.4 million people in south africa
the term colored means people of mixed
racial background
i didn't choose that term myself it's
also the native language of 4.6
of asian south africans it's also the
native language of 1.5 percent of black
south africans that's about 600 000
people and there are 10 to 15 million
second language speakers in south africa
in namibia it's the native language of
10 or 11 percent of people including 60
of the white population it's also widely
used as a lingua franca and most people
can speak it as a second or third
language so
how did the story of afrikaans begin
dutch-speaking settlers arrived in
southern africa in the year 1652 when
the dutch east
india company set up a resupply station
at cape town for its ships traveling to
the indian subcontinent and to southeast
asia
their goal was to get fresh water food
and other supplies for their long sea
journeys when the local koisan people
people who speak koisan languages were
unwilling to meet the trade demands of
the dutch east india company the company
drove them out of the area into the
inland and replaced them with european
settlers and with slaves from other
parts of africa
most of the farmers who were known as
bowers were former laborers of the dutch
east india company and most of them were
dutch but some of them were french or
german too upset with the conditions
placed upon them by the dutch east india
company the european settlers began
expanding
inland so they could farm outside of the
area controlled by the company the dutch
east india company wanted to prevent
this inland expansion so they outlawed
the expansion
ended european immigration and increased
the number of slaves instead
some of the slaves were brought from the
indian subcontinent and from
present-day malaysia and indonesia
britain seized control of the cape
colony in 1815 and began to import
british settlers
the british eventually took steps to
eliminate slavery and to put heavy
restrictions on the boer farmers large
numbers of bowers migrated further
inland to escape british rule
setting up their own communities and
encountering various native african
communities along the way
after a series of conflicts with the
british called the boer wars south
africa became a unified british colony
until its independence in 1961 but this
is lang focus we're supposed to focus on
languages why is all this history
important well it's to help you imagine
the conditions under which the language
spoken by those dutch settlers changed
and eventually became afrikans
exactly how afrikans developed is a
highly debated subject with some people
insisting that it's a natural direct
descendant of dutch
while other people insist that it's
actually a creole language that arose
when slaves and laborers attempted to
learn dutch
if you're not sure what creole languages
are you can have a look at my video on
pidgin and creole languages right here
nobody knows exactly what process has
caused afrikaans to develop but it's
unlikely that
either of those two theories is 100 true
in the early years of the cape colony
there was a continuous stream of
dutch-speaking immigrants
as well as other europeans who learned
dutch as a second language there were
also many local speakers of kauisan
languages
who learned dutch as a second language
and there were also african and asian
slaves who learned dutch as a second
language
local africans and slaves most likely
spoke a dutch-based pidgin language at
some point
typically a creole language arises when
a pidgin language becomes the native
language of the next generation usually
without a lot of influence from
speakers of the original standard
language for example slave owners or
colonial settlers but in the case of
afrikaans there was always
extensive contact with native speakers
of dutch more specifically the emerging
dialect called cape dutch
on top of that standard dutch and not
cake dutch was the language that was
taught in schools both of these factors
would help cape dutch remain relatively
similar to standard dutch
so even if afrikaans is a creole
language it's more like a partial creole
or a semi creole language
two creole languages that i'm familiar
with are tok pisin and bislama which are
spoken in melanesia and they are
english-based creoles
both of those languages consist of
mainly english vocabulary but with the
syntax grammar and phonology of an
oceanic language they're essentially new
languages that got their vocabulary from
english but afrikaans is not like that
its grammar became simplified but the
syntax of the language is basically the
same as dutch and its phonology is also
close to dutch
so it seems that afrikaans developed
from a form of dutch that was influenced
by second language speakers
rather than a completely new creole
language featuring dutch vocabulary
that's my personal assessment but i'm
sure some people will disagree
and that's fine afrikaans continued to
develop until it was legally recognized
as its own language in 1925. so
how is afrikaans different from dutch
loanwords the vocabulary of afrikaans
was influenced by the various languages
that it came in contact with
for example malay the word anther
meaning almost
comes from the malay word the word fire
meaning much comes from the malay word
banyak portuguese the word
combat meaning blanket comes from the
portuguese word
the word growl meaning cattle enclosure
comes from the portuguese word
we have a similar word chorale in
english koisan languages
the words for a lot of things in the
local african environment came from
kohisan languages for example
plants and animals this animal is called
a kudu but the overwhelming majority of
afrikaans vocabulary is dutch more than
90
or as high as 95 spelling afrikaans
underwent some spelling simplifications
to make the written language more
reflective of the spoken language i
won't mention
all the changes but here are some
examples the dutch digraph
ij pronounced i became just a y in
afrikaans so we have the dutch word
which is spelled like this in afrikaans
but dutch words ending with li jk
pronounced as lik are spelled l-i-k in
afrikaans and that's a more accurate
reflection of the real pronunciation
dutch t-i-o-n became s-i-o-n in
afrikaans so we have the dutch word
not show now and this became the
spelling in afrikaans national
these dutch diphthongs which are
actually pronounced identically by many
dutch speakers
all became spelled ou in afrikaans so
the dutch words
frau and thou are spelled like this in
afrikaans
fro do there are also some other
spelling changes that represent new
pronunciations in afrikaans
for example afrikaans merged the dutch
consonants z and s
to a single sound spelt s so the dutch
word
became in afrikaans a similar phonetic
change can also be found in the northern
netherlands but it's not represented in
writing only in speech
afrikaans also merged together the dutch
sounds represented by ch
and g to a single sound spelt g and
again a similar merging also happened in
the netherlands but
not in spelling only in sound in
afrikaans when the g sound is preceded
by an s
it is written as s k so we have the
dutch word soul
and the afrikaans word school between
two vowels the dutch g
and v consonants are omitted in
afrikaans look at these dutch words and
now the afrikaans equivalents
notice that the second vowel requires a
diacritic so that we know to pronounce
these as two separate vowels and not as
one diphthong there are many more
spelling changes but those are a few
examples to give you a sense of how
things changed
verbs the verb system in afrikaans is
quite simple compared to dutch
first of all the simple past isn't used
except for eight basic verbs
for all other verbs the perfect tense is
used instead which is also possible in
dutch too so here's the dutch sentence
meaning i watched
ik and now here's the afrikaans sentence
so notice that we used the perfect tense
in afrikaans because there is no past
tense but this afrikaan sentence is
similar to the dutch perfect tense
sentence
but notice that the way the past
participle is formed is a little
different
also notice that the form of the verb
for have is different these are both the
present tense form of the verb meaning
to have
the one in dutch is conjugated for first
person singular but afrikaans verbs
don't change according to person or
number so the dutch verb will change in
other sentences but in afrikaans it will
always be
there was also no plu perfect tense in
afrikaans pluperfect is like
had watched instead the perfect form
would be used
so let's just jump into a few more
example sentences and look at these
differences as well as some others the
next sentences mean
i talked to my children in dutch it kept
me in kindergarten
and in afrikaans i could put my
condition
first of all notice the difference in
personal pronouns in dutch
and in afrikaans and then notice the
different forms of the verb meaning to
have
the next word met means with and next we
can see that the possessive pronouns are
different
in dutch main and in afrikaans may
next is the word for children but notice
that the plural form is different
notice that the word order is exactly
the same and that the second verb goes
at the end in afrikaans which is the
same as in dutch and also the same as in
german
the next sentences mean did you have a
good new year first in dutch
new york and in afrikaans
in english it's like have you a good new
year had
again we see the different forms of the
verb meaning to have then we see the
different spelling of the personal
pronoun yai meaning you then we have the
indefinite article which has been
shortened in afrikaans then notice that
the word for good is slightly different
then after that notice the slight
difference in the words for a new year
and finally the past participle of the
verb meaning to have
is the same in both sentences now let's
look at a similar sentence but with a
little change
this one means did he have a good new
year in dutch
and in afrikaans look at the first word
and notice that the dutch verb
conjugation changes this is the third
person singular form of the verb
but the verb form stays the same in
afrikaans and next we see that the
personal pronoun
hai meaning he is spelled differently
after that the rest of the words are the
same as in the sentences up above
the next sentences mean we will live we
will die
in dutch missoula levin stethen
and in afrikaans
notice here that the subject pronoun for
we is different in dutch the subject
pronoun is ve
but the object pronoun similar to us in
english is ons
in afrikaans aunts is both the subject
and the object pronoun
next notice that the future tense in
dutch is formed using zulen plus the
infinitive
in afrikaans it's formed by using sal
plus the verb
and there really isn't an infinitive in
afrikaans there's just one single verb
form this part here is the same as the
present tense form
so we can see that there are some
differences between dutch and afrikaans
but
generally the vocabulary is very similar
and probably very easy to recognize once
you're aware of those general
differences
and the word order is basically the same
so how well can dutch speakers and
afrikan speakers understand each other
the answer to this question depends on
who you ask but generally they seem to
be mutually intelligible to a moderate
level
with afrikaans speakers being able to
understand dutch better than dutch
speakers can understand afrikaans
there are a couple of important factors
in intelligibility one of them is
accent i've heard from a few dutch
people and from a few afrikans people
that they can understand certain
speakers of the other language very well
but other speakers are harder to
understand and that might be because
certain dutch dialects have
pronunciation that is more similar to
afrikaans than
others and there are also a lot of
second language speakers of afrikaans
whose accent might be difficult for
native dutch speakers to understand
another factor is register register
means the level of formality used
now if the speakers of both languages
use the standard formal variety of their
language and they don't use any local
variations or
slang then they'll probably understand
each other much better formal speech
basically resembles the written language
and the speakers of either language can
basically understand the other one when
it's written
a common question that i see written on
the internet is should i learn afrikaans
before learning dutch would that help me
to learn dutch later on
i would say that that's probably a bad
idea to learn afrikaans just because you
want to learn dutch later
it probably would end up confusing you
when you learn dutch later on because
dutch is similar to afrikaans but more
complex i would say that the best reason
to learn afrikaans would be because you
have a deep cultural interest in south
africa and you want to spend some time
in that country
or in namibia so the question of the day
for speakers of afrikaans and dutch how
well can you guys understand each other
leave your comments and your experiences
down below
and for everyone else i don't have a
question of the day so why don't you ask
a question to the afrikaans and dutch
speakers that sounds good
be sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and instagram
and i want to say thanks to all of my
patreon supporters for continuing to
make langfocus possible
thank you for watching and have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
[Music]
you